what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
another episode of pearl daily where I
cover this week's treachery debauchery
and craziness before I start make sure
you like the video that's the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams please guys let's
get to
2,500 likes on this video a like is free
also guys my producer King is fighting
in a boxing match this Sunday out here
in the good old city of London I will be
attending as well as our production team
and some of the talents if you're
interested in attending and meeting some
of us the link to Kings Instagram will
be in the description it is Sunday the
8th of October at the Scala Event Center
in Kings Cross London okay so today we
have a couple of different topics guys
I've been I feel like I've been talking
back and forth to the Daily wire all
week I I don't know why we can't have a
debate a dis okay okay a discussion on
the pros and cons of marriage in 2023 so
Ben Shapiro tweeted he didn't say at me
okay he didn't at me guys but Ben just
at me next time okay all right so Ben
says marriage is good and you should get
married marriage will make you a better
person you should date with an eye
towards marriage seeking commonality of
values the single most important
foundation for a lasting marriage thank
you for coming to my TED Talk I disagree
where do I disagree I want to I want to
I want to break down every single one of
Ben's statements so marriage is good I
do believe that the ideal marriage of
two virgins getting married and staying
married for a lifetime I do believe that
is good you should get married I do not
believe it is always in men's best
interests in 2023 to get married I think
that maybe wealthier men have an easier
time with marriage than broke men that
we have to realize that the average man
in this country is about 5'9 510 makes
about
$55,000 a year and is about
1880s these are all give or take
depending on which website you look on
but a lot of times their prescriptions
really depend on the guy um and when we
look at the average woman who's about
170b
55 um one out of three is had an
abortion one out of four has had an STD
and 90% have been on birth control at
some point in their lives I would argue
that it is not always in men's best
interest to get married and telling men
to get married without warning them of
the risks and telling them and giving
them every opportunity to protect
themselves really is um I I would argue
negligent I believe it is negligent to
tell Men by and large that they should
just get married as much as I as a
Catholic would love to see The Return of
families and traditionalism I I would
argue you will never see that until you
change the laws what the tradcons will
often say is well it'll take so much
time to change the law laws in the
meantime you should just get married
well my question is why would the
institutions change if they keep having
willing customers that sign up so Ben
says marriage will make you a better
person I would argue that is very
dependent on the man and the wife there
are absolutely nagging belittling wives
that make marriage a living hell hole
for men and no it does not make them a
happy healthier person Ben says you
should date with an eye towards marriage
seeking a commonality of values the
single most important foundation for a
lasting marriage Ben is really selling
here that if you just find a woman with
a commonality of values that it is not
the risks that that it is not as risky
as the Pearl doom and gloomer will say
now some of this is an inference so you
know take it with a grain of salt but I
would argue that even a 10% chance of
getting your life absolutely destroyed
in divorce is still pretty risky we all
know that even amongst religious couples
the divorce rate is still 25 35 45% and
what happens is we go back and forth
with the tradcons and they'll say oh
well it's lower than you guys are saying
you're doom and gloomer and what I
typically see them do is manipulate the
stats now how do they do that if the
average age of divorce is 46 I would
argue you're not painting a full picture
by using the stats of men in their 20s
and 30s I know many men that were very
happily married in their 20s and 30s
before getting their lives absolutely
destroyed in their 40s and 50s a more
honest answer would be surveying the men
in their 60s and 70s what their opinion
is on marriage if I had to guess it
would be very different than the men
married today the other issue is is they
downplay the difference in the time
period that we are in most women have
been addicted to attention from the time
they were very very young this creates a
completely different pool of women that
men have to choose from the women are
more and overweight than ever and
really when we don't acknowledge these
things and tell men to just get married
with a system that profits off of them
having their lives ruined it there's no
real solution because you're not even
acknowledging the problem you're
downplaying that it exists I would argue
that is negligent um the single most
important foundation for a lasting
marriage I would agree commonality of
values however I do not think that is a
foolproof plan Ben shipiro is an
extremely high IQ individual I am sure
it was very apparent from a young age to
Ben's family friends and community that
he was going to be a success I don't
think you could talk to Ben Shapiro for
more than five minutes without noticing
this guy is crazy smart women notice
that type of things the level of respect
that Ben Shapiro is going to get in a
room is very different from the average
man he has amassed a net worth of over
50 million according to Google and being
that he worth over $50 million he's
going to have a very different
experience in marriage so Jordan
Peterson actually weighed in and I think
he's taken my side I think I think I'm
dividing the daily wire on this and I
want to point out that um the older men
are much more taking Pearl's side than
the younger men which again supports my
original hypothesis was that was that
Andrew claven says that Pearl has a
point
and the younger men call me a doom and
gloomer and call the men crybabies you
know um and just say get married anyway
now Jordan Peterson comes in and I I am
a Jordan Peterson fan so Jordan Peterson
weighs in and says but Ben Shapiro the
divorce and custody laws need upgrading
so this idea that all of the right wing
is just saying oh men sign up anyway
imagine imagine okay you you had to
signed you got a contract okay
imagine and this contract says that your
partner has all of the leverage and this
contract says your business partner is
paid to leave you yes they're paid to
break this contract and this business
partner will be rewarded for ruining
your life financially and emotionally if
we take the religion out of it because
the facts don't care about your religion
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm a Catholic but
we have to be honest here um you would
never sign that contract but the truth
of the matter is until child custody
laws change you will not see women act
different and and my appeal to the Daily
wire is let's advocate for these laws I
want to see 20 videos on everyone's
channel advocating for this stuff
because you guys are the most
influential voice in the media I would
argue I don't know many people you could
argue Maybe Fox News but I really don't
know many people that have as much pull
as the daily wire why is this not the
number one issue on all platforms
instead of just waving away men's real
concerns and saying get married anyway
so I tweet and I'm asking we it doesn't
even have to be a debate but a real
conversation about Solutions in this
Society so is that a no from the daily
wire to have a debate on marriage it
should be a good discussion if you want
the truth to come out and the facts are
on your side why not have it it was
important enough and guys it was
actually five daily wire hosts I forgot
it was important enough for five of your
hosts to respond to me let's set a date
good Pearl 26y Old Pearl okay I got Matt
Walsh Jeremy
boring is it boring I've been saying
Boeing this whole time I'm sorry I'm
sorry Ben Shapiro and Andrew claven and
Jordan Peterson five hosts to respond to
me yet I'm being told no for a debate
but we've talked about this all week
okay Andrew claven said and I want to I
want to break this down long before you
or Tate or any of the red pills I was an
outspoken anti-feminist but also an
anti- misogynist femininity with its
work of Soul making and homemaking is a
spiritual value and both the right and
left have become materialists so
degrading the feminine spear that now
people can't even Define what the word
Woman and think a man in a dress will
suffice I don't is is he accusing me of
misogyny I I don't know I don't I'm not
even saying he is or he isn't but it's
like I'm like okay so can we debate and
he's like before the the red pill I was
an outspoken anti-feminist and anti-
misogynist okay femininity with its work
of Soul making and homemaking is a
spiritual value
okay we don't okay and both the left and
the right have become materialists so
degrading the feminine
spear that now people can't even Define
what the okay I don't what does that
have to do with the debate this is what
I was confused okay so of course as per
so of course as pearly things has noted
marriage is broken true okay so I agree
with pearl that's what I hear but to Def
but to deride the institution and
denigrate women is he accusing me of
denigrating women how many times on the
show have I said there are exceptional
awesome women out there but the stats
are not on our side ladies not in 2023
okay these aren't ideas that can be
debated they are just
inarticulate cries oh no Andrew this
sounds like something like a chick would
say to psychoanalyze me they're
inarticulate cries of pains from of so
from souls in a materialistic
hell okay you can't TR okay this this
part I really disagreed with you can't
treat bodies as sex toys and then
complain when you wake up in bed with an
abusive pimp or a crazy Andrew
Andrew you're 70 years old okay so you
might not know the reality of the
situation um okay what is a we
have to Define first what what is a
um really there are not enough
wives to go around around there are not
enough wives to go around for the
average man there are more only fans
workers sex workers and cam models than
there are teachers in this country under
the age of 35 so and it's kind of and
he's kind of again putting it back on
the men it's so interesting whenever men
have a complaint we have such a gut
instinct to just tell them it's their
fault himson are vicious people
what did you expect Andrew the truth of
the matter is
typically the men that are actually
getting screwed in marriage are men that
wanted
traditionalism the guys that are pimps
that are out screwing everybody they
don't get married what incentive would
those men have to settle down when they
have all of the women do you think that
Drake will get
married do you think most of these men
that have access to all of the women
will get married some do and we can look
at exceptions but I I would argue that
most men that get screwed in divorce
that I have spoken to actually were good
men that wanted to be traditional and
really this situation happened because
they had a predatory woman they had a
woman that they thought was something
that she wasn't
and
really saying what did you expect to a
guy that hasn't seen his kids in two
years has spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars trying to get his children I
would
argue is wrong it's wrong and it's not
correct the men that are getting screwed
in divorce are not The Pimps they are
the good men that want to do the right
thing but the issue is when we have the
incentive structure that we do even good
women will even seemingly good women
when they're not feeling the right way
will sign up on top of that we have an
entire media dedicated to telling women
that were amazing and special and that
the man is just not doing enough look at
how even one of the daily wire host
reacted to the Crowder divorce when
Candice Owens covered the Crowder
divorce she alleged that Steven Crowder
was emotionally abusive what is
emotional abuse this woman was a
stay-at-home housewife wife with a nanny
crying emotional abuse this is the world
that we are living in and all of the
media slandered his name Crowder is a
traditional guy this if this happened to
a rich successful media personality that
believes in Christian
values what chance does the average man
have I just heard a couple from our show
today I just ran into him I was I was
going for a walk ran into a couple from
our show they're getting married I'm
Overjoyed I love seeing people have a
happy ending but what I don't love is
men thinking they're signing up for one
thing and getting absolutely destroyed
later because they have no idea what
they're signing up for and the truth of
the matter is the facts don't care about
your religion yes I am a Catholic it
does not make me happy to talk about
these things but the truth of the matter
when we look at the numbers when it
comes to issues reg regarding divorce
the numbers are not on our side the
truth of the matter is many of the men
at the daily wire are out of touch for
two reasons one they are a 1% man in
society I'm sorry but most men's lives
do not involve them becoming
multi-millionaire Rich famous men now
you could argue that maybe they weren't
that at one point but women are experts
at selecting for the traits that make a
man successful later I believe that the
only solution is changing the laws and I
question why they keep coming at the red
pill instead of having a real
conversation about changing the divorce
laws so I beg you I plead with you daily
wire please even if it's not with me
have a real conversation about Solutions
about marriage question the politicians
that you're interviewing this election
season about how they're going to
advocate for men's issues and more
importantly children's issues this
election season children deserve a
mother and a father father and children
deserve two parent households with the
incentive structure that you have you
will see marriage
disappear regardless of myself the Tates
or any other red pill influencer